DANIEL BUCHNER: Cool.
So Daniel Buchner.
I was formerly in Brazil
for about five years.
I led all of our initiatives
surrounding Web Components
for everything from
spec interactions
to how we actually would use
the components for things
like making Firefox OS
app development easier.
One of my 20% projects
while was there
was actually writing
X-Tag library.
Weird for a PM, I guess.
It's awesome.
It's our version of
Polymer essentially.
It does a little bit
less, less than Polymer.
No data binding,
stuff like that.
It's simply about
Custom Elements.
But I'll walk through
what it does do.
So interesting
point, we actually
use the same polyfill
layer that Polymer does.
So if you already were
to be using Polymer
and you wanted to use any
Web Component from X-Tag that
was built with this library,
all you would need to include
is a small-- the
actual library itself,
which is 12k, instead of
redundantly loading everything
that Polymer loads.
It takes care of most
of the platform stuff.
If you wanted to
use a part, you can
include that platform JS and
include X-Tag, the library,
on top of that as well.
And it will operate just
fine in the presence
of only the native
Web Component APIs.
It also enhances those APIs.
It gives you an interface
that's just a little bit more
ergonomic.
It links your custom attributes,
getters and setters, together.
You saw that with Polymer.
So we have our own
little dialect,
our own way of declaring that.
But we do the same thing there.
Also it provides some
great event features,
stuff I'll show you in the
demo, as well as hooking up
a pseudo system and a mixin API.
So that if you create
something like maybe-- iframe
and image have source attributes
and you want to just have
the source attribute able to be
applied to multiple elements,
we have a mixin called SRC.
And you mix that
into any component.
And when you change source,
downloads your data.
Makes it available to you.
So it's awesome.
Let's just jump
right in the demo.
So you can click.
If anyone's following
along, I will--oops.
Actually, it's already loaded.
So here we have our code.
I'm going to walk
through it really
quickly just so we
understand what we're doing.
This is what an X-Tag
created element looks like.
So xtag.register.
This is all maps that document
that register element.
You'll see some
of the same things
you are used to-- lifecycle.
Obviously those APIs map
straight to Web Components.
Created, that's for when
element instantiates
any way that it may happen.
Insert and Removed--
this is when the element
is removed from the DOM
and inserted in the DOM.
Accessors-- This is how we
actually link up our attributes
to setters and getters.
So we have a Super Mario
attribute, or Super Mario
getter.
So if you say
this.supermario, you're
going to be able to access it
there or through the attribute
super-mario.
This is also declaring it
as a Boolean attribute.
So it doesn't
actually have a value.
But X-Tag handles that for you.
So if you say
this.super-mario=true,
it knows to put that attribute
on your element without
a value.
We also have methods.
So if you want to say,
here's some methods
that are going to go
on my custom element,
you can see we have jump and
play sound as well as an events
object that does
some nice wrapping.
So what tap is
actually an event that
wraps click and
touch for you, so you
don't have to worry
about where you're at.
It just works.
As well as animation end
and some other things.
You know, animation end is
still prefixed in some browsers.
We go ahead and take
care of that for you.
So all you say is I want
an [? animation end ?]
event on this element,
and we'll make sure
that the right
events are handled.
So let's check it out.
Looks pretty familiar.
People are probably
used to this.
Let's put Mario into the DOM.
MARIO: It's me, Mario.
DANIEL BUCHNER: So
when he enters the DOM,
we have this part of the demos
playing here inserted, right?
So that's actually
what's happening.
It's going and saying,
let's play this sound,
which is a function that's
on your custom element.
Let's do some other stuff.
That jump, that tap that we
had and the jump function.
Yeah.
Let's do that.
So that's all there.
And Mario, he's
feeling a little low.
He might want to become super.
So you can do that.
You can go back.
And remember, it's
a Boolean attribute.
So I can say zero, falsy.
X-Tag handles all this
for you, converts it
to truthy and falsy.
So I can say zero.
It's going to go back.
Also, just to show you the
power of getters and setters,
let's say plus plus also works.
Right?
This is just JS.
It's just the platform,
the DOM, stuff
you're going to be used to
more and more now that we're
returning back to that platform.
And let's say I'm
done with my demo
and I really want him to leave.
MARIO: Hey, you very good.
See you next time.
DANIEL BUCHNER: Yeah.
So this is all stuff you
can do with custom elements.
I would encourage you, no
matter what you get into,
what library around custom
elements-- X-Tag, Polymer,
both-- just get into them.
I mean, the web is the Napoleon
Dynamite of the platform,
then surely web
components are Pedro.
Your wildest dreams
are going to come true.
Just to give you one
quick demo because I think
we have a couple more minutes.
When they talk about
non-visual text--
this is really important--
think outside the box.
Not everything has
to be a UI element.
Here we've actually created
something really cool
to do element queries.
So I don't know if you are
familiar with media queries.
Think about what if you
could have media queries
scope to just a certain element
so that max width wasn't
300 pixels of the
whole window, it
was 300 pixels of
a specific element.
This is a non-visual element
that we have that actually--
see how they're morphing?
I'm able to drag them and
get different queries.
They're just changing.
Right?
This is all done through
a non-visual tag.
And it's handled
by the Shadow DOMs.
So all the mechanisms
to allow you
that functionality are
baked into a non-visual tag.
Explore the DOM.
Explore tags, no matter
if they're visual or not.
Thank you for your time.
And questions welcome.
[APPLAUSE]